that that is fed's best chance here try
to get as much chaos in well I think for
fedos he is a combative player by nature
but it can backfire and look at this he
plays the Petro defense from the black
side which I think is a good choice
against Magnus because Magnus Carlson is
the better player that's clear but what
fedos where he can backfire is just like
against Aliva fua in that fourth game he
was lost right he was down a couple
pawns but in the time scramble is where
he was able to shine so I think that
fedos he needs to keep the games going
Magnus is a brilliant speed chest player
he's won the speed chest Championship he
made it to the finals of the bullet
Chess Championship but that's where he
has the most opportunity to go wrong
late stages of the game when you don't
have enough time so I think that fos he
chose a wise opening in game one we
would have laughed them out of Chess we
would have told them this isn't the game
for you you know you're too timid it's
all about placing the pieces on their
best squares yes the Queens have gone I
I guess Magnus is simply arguing that
there's enough forces there's enough of
his army left I think players they think
let's go for that but against Magnus
Carlson it's a totally different game so
it's something that you need to take
care of immediately he falls back with
the bishop and yes uh the Queens are off
the board but the gloves are still on
because I think the players want to
still fight it out Magnus we've seen him
do crazy things in the end game it's
going to be a battle it's going to be a
slow one but we've got a game on our
hands it's far from over when you're
playing against Magnus I think it only
gets scarier when the Queens are off
equal
it's just about whether Magnus can uh
exert that magic a bit later start for
both of these games both uh matches I
think they're just settling in without
creating any major threats stopping that
white Pawn from moving forward on the
left side of our screen play that I've
seen I've seen it in the tour season
last year I've seen it in the cherel
Masters so far this year the queen has
attack and needs to find a good Square
he's 17 and it's just amazing to hear
him talk and his play is a true
reflection of his personality I think he
worked this end game magic we've been
talking about this queenless middle game
we'll call it and uh here I've got to
say first glance I like white purely
because of this night that he's just
installed on the C6 square but uh black
has reasons to be optimistic too Robert
yeah this is a position where it
resembles the other game in that white
has the pair of Bishops that's not
actually a bad thing at this stage of
the game with so many pieces remaining
on the board a white can go after some
of Black's targets and black is not
creating a pass Pawn what's going on
here whoa that's going on here that's
what's going on here w we didn't expect
that and uh again the blue arrow
indicating that Black's only move or at
least by far the best move is Rook takes
Bishop but uh now you have to be careful
if Pawn takes suddenly a deadly check
and your Bishop will simply drop off
next move so Magnus initiating the
tactics let's just show what he okay
he's playing play Pawn takes Pawn he
needed to play Rook takes bishop and uh
basically admit that uh okay if Rook
takes there are tricks in Black's favor
this time with a nice pin but Pawn takes
Pawn Robert do you think this is going
to backfire fed say of playing that move
instantly because now that Knight on D7
if it continues to move say to E5 well
oh and he doesn't move too late does fed
of the right idea wrong move order I
still feel like he has chances to
survive this game but to what end what
light squares are actually valuable
that's an essential question so I like
the way that fedos is handling this I
think this gives him the best practical
chances still requires a bit of prep
right now I'm expecting fedf to move his
Knight he does it Knight to B6 the
evalar hits it and Magnus just continues
to keep opening up the position the
lines for the Bishops and the the lines
for the Rooks and the diagonals for the
Bishops what he could have done instead
and it was just a on move play from
fedos that would have kept him in the
game rather than opening the Rooks up
Bishop to G3 just just try to blockade
this D Pawn so the Rooks don't have open
files when you're down material
especially when your opponent has two
Rooks just one for yourself you need to
keep those Rooks contained so this would
have been a good choice instead what we
see in the game the Rooks are loose they
are free to roam about the board and now
one of them is off the board and that's
bad news for black because that A5 Pawn
is tender the defile remains open black
can't keep everything under his control
and Magnus Carlson for sure is winning
this first game David 100% it's all
about that uh Target on A5 pretty much
indefensible in the uh kind of short
term and uh this white a PA not only
does it promote on a light Square Guided
by your Bishop but it's pretty much
Unstoppable you have no Rooks left as
black yeah Knights are terrible at
stopping these Corner pawns these Rook
pawns so once the White Knight Retreats
takes this Pawn it's a matter of time
before fed has to resign we saw him sit
back exhale a moment ago he knows it's
over the white Rook doesn't look
impressive now but it will soon join the
fun and uh I think we'll see very simple
plan Black's counter blate far too slow
and uh Magnus he's going porn hunting
he's going to hunt down the full point
in this game uh soon closing out the
victory again just in the space of one
or two moves this is how strong the top
players are they punish you one small
imperceptible slip and here we go Knight
takes porn inevitable just a
straightforward plan Magnus about to
bank it um we think Tanya should we go
to the other game where there's still
action on the board
definitely I just want to say this is
how strong Magnus Carlson can be
especially in these positions I mean we
were talking about an equal opening an
outcome where White had nothing and then
just out of nowhere Magnus comes up with
a winning position how did it happen
when did it all go so wrong it's just
unbelievable how he makes these things
just appear on the board and makes chess
look so easy it's insane he's playing
against one of the best players in the
world he has a completely winning
position out of a completely equal open
opening Magnus Carlson just doing Magnus
things I think it's a good time David to
jump over to our other board Which is
far from a queenless position it's an
exciting middle game Robert what do you
make of what we're seeing on the left
side of our screen between Dennis lazic
and Jose Martinez it's definitely
heating up on the left hand side board
because they're open diagonals for both
players yui open space it is good for
the player with the pair of Bishops as
Jose Martinez he cameras on the bottom
left hand side of our screen but Dennis
lvic he just doesn't back down against
anyone it's super impressive the game
between Magnus and fed is officially
over no surprises there Magnus takes
game one